لما يكون في انتشار من الظهر ولا الخوف
يعني يكون خاطئه
اثنين حياه تتملك
المشاعر ويعني الافكار يعني اول قرارات
الغير منطقيه تصبح هي السائد في هذه
الحاله زي ما ذكرته اليوم ما لها تفسير
اليوم انت الكتاب والتغطيه كانت عاليه زي
بعض الكتابات ثلاث مرات كانت التغطيه من
الافراد انا ما اتكلم عن المؤسسات من
الافراد اللي هم يبيعون اليوم كانت تغطيه
ثلاثه اربعه مع ذلك احنا نرى هؤلاء كثير
او شريحه منهم هي اللي تضغط السهم
[موسيقى]
احنا نتكلم على تقييمات كانت قبل الرفع
الفائده وبعدين صار في ارتفاعات في
الفائده اكيد التقييم هيختلف والمفروض انه
يختلف لكن انا اللي اشوفه اليوم ماله
علاقه التقليم صراحه يعني الشركه مهما
يعني نبره مثلا مكرر ربحيه عشره طب
الاشاره خص من عشره ما لها علاقه في مساله
مكر ربحيه انا ما اتكلم على 20 ولا 25